yeah welcome to this video playing fruit
scar from the US if we assume that this
flag is correct um let's go for the
zillion night off
hmm oh I'm Bishop c4 Queen B 6 is
probably a bit bit weird there should be
three is not exactly a move that white
objects to play okay he doesn't really
okay I don't might take it
ok
the point is upon
Stewart looks dangerous of course maybe
should i drop back not sure b6 really
sacrifice probably at some point here he
needs to care
hmm yeah hard to tell i mean it's it's a
pawn at the structure so black is if
black is not busted in like the next
four or five moves then then he's
winning this is the nature of such such
positions he probably needs to do
something very drastic here and then he
plays h3 this is funny I three okay
Bishop seven simply on this is something
better yeah I wonder about Bishop six if
I play Bishop e7 he might take there and
then it's not so clear how I continue
but it's I can play king after seven
it's hard to believe really that Bishop
e6 should work here
h3 is really a funky move what was the
idea of this okay he made the sacrifice
anyway the question now is some protect
or not to protect or not to protect so I
have played this hip for me I don't I
don't see what you got is doing now it
can retreat but 94 yeah but this really
shouldn't be enough compensation 95
problem
yeah 95 also covers f5 he goes f5 night
c4 and it's not clear that f4 is really
helping image anyway
yeah night see form and 23 problem
right G 696 would be the simple way to
do it on knight c6 yeah that's how to
tell I mean probably this isn't
sufficient for white but you always have
this kind of shaky King position I need
one or two moves to consolidate here you
can take and play you five uh-huh yeah
this I didn't consider at all maybe it
maybe a maybe it is a good idea but I
can give the check I can give this check
and but it's good probably not I came on
just all the way back
we're treating the night and isn't such
a great thing anyway just rook e8 and
King g8 and I'm a P sub
41 porn a peaceful upon but ok um yeah
II five maybe a thread this may be a
thread because of their fault but I can
actually move the night if you place in
five I don't need to take I mean yeah
but I probably want to just King g8 yeah
come on not not spend too much time
maybe not the the best move but
hopefully am a sufficient one just age
six come on
hmm it's not helping with this one
simply
check
to tick with the Queen that's the still
this five move came yeah this isn't so
bad actually I hope
huh yeah it's still a bit of a shaky
King
check
huh yeah it's still owe this this is
surprising let's try to get rid of the
night ii five looks strange to be really
strange what does this help I mean this
doesn't open up the position really
check
check
yeah i'm covering d6 now
and I'm trying to do something on the
default myself with look
check
check
ok
threatening mate myself so i hope this
counts for something check check check
check
time morning we should be force what I
want to do check
okay counter checkmate you rarely see
that wow this was really a very shaky
for a while I don't know around here
this is the kind of position where a
computer defense and makes it looks
really look miss Wow makes it look
really easy but in a practical game it's
it's really tricky again comp wants to
take on d5 well it's probably out but
I'll take the five kintu h7 and and it's
over and this this really are you can
play a 5 North which you didn't do this
is yeah again the computer gives this as
minus two points something which is
probably I mean probably all right but
for a human but this wasn't even if I
really wasn't afraid of I don't know if
I for something like really blasting up
the position as quickly as possible you
know this is what I intended to do and
it seems to work but yeah I don't know
this looks the King King is a bit error
here yeah and the game I hope that this
was fairly convincing yeah yeah here
it's it's basically gone he really
shocked me who the throat g5 but okay
yeah this is actually better i can i can
take here no didn't see that in
instantly winning on g2
okay this also kept a winning position
it seems as even a first mate here with
kingi for kicking here okay but I hope
my my move my moves were okay yeah it's
actually fast made for a couple of holes
alright thanks for watching